karine bègles au fco bonjour merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors c'est une annonce qui prend tout
le monde de court
comment comprendre cette démission juste
après le discours de vladimir poutine
dans lequel il annonce je le rappelle
des réformes de la constitution
bonjour
effectivement cette annonce ça a été une
surprise pour pour les médias pour les
hommes politiques puisque après le
discours de bédénik et après le message
de la dignité d'un général ce monde
s'attend à ce que les niches du
gouvernement se mettent au travail pour
réaliser les grandes lignes qui sont
énoncés dans c'est ce discours programme
1 or il semblerait qu'il y ait ici une
couture dans le mode de fonctionnement
qui pose quand même un certain nombre de
questions
c'est la fin de la période n'était ds
mais des diètes politiquement est envoyé
vers le conseil de sécurité qui est un
organe certes important pour déterminer
la politique sécuritaire de l'état mais
qui est aussi une sinécure où beaucoup
d'anciens ministres gouverneurs et hauts
fonctionnaires donc sa carrière
politique est terminée
qui va prendre la succession 1 le
premier nom qui vient effectivement à
l'esprit c'est celui de coudre henin
dans ce cas là cela signifierait un
virage néolibéral est extrêmement
important en russie avec tous les
dangers que cela peut présenter comme le
voyons en france avec macron donc être
dans l'intérêt de la russie de mener en
de mener une politique absolument
impopulaire qui en plus à des résultats
une efficacité
largement discutable nous verrons quel
sera le choix fait par le président dean
finalement l'autre possibilité est la
mise en place de l'opération successeur
mais quatre ans avant les nouvelles
élections c'est quand même un délit qui
est extrêmement longue ça peut être un
mandat en soi donc cela en fait soulève
aussi la question de savoir est ce que
finalement va décider d'aller jusqu'à la
fin de son mandat présidentiel
ou bien d'ici un ou deux ans un bâton
bras droit des élections anticipées
en fait beaucoup de questions se posent
pour l'instant et est encore trop tôt
près vous est ce que le premier ministre
démissionnaire a pris sa décision
pendant le discours du président
vladimir poutine ou ses pensées depuis
plusieurs jours selon vous moi je ne
pense pas que ce genre de décisions se
prennent de manière spontanée impulsive
c'est une opération politique qui est
menée et en général qui se prévoit dans
tous ses détails le comme la préparation
l'annnonce de la préparation d'une
réforme de la constitution
ce gouvernement en fait appartient à un
certain mode de gouvernance
lorsque l'on joint l'annoncent fait des
volontés de réforme de la constitution
qui renforce les pouvoirs du législatif
au détriment des pouvoirs présidentiels
on voit qu'il ya un glissement vers un
régime parlementaire
donc ce gouvernement sort ce qui ne veut
pas dire que tous les ministres de ce
gouvernement s'en sortir ça veut dire
que certains vont pouvoir rester ça veut
dire surtout qu'il va y avoir un nouveau
premier ministre
alors lors de sa prise de parole en
parmi les mesures annoncées par vlad
poutine il y a donc vous le disiez le
renforcement du rôle du parlement dans
la formation du gouvernement vladimir
poutine jauge le pays je cite mur pour
cela qu'est ce qu'il faut entendre avec
ce terme mur oublions pas qu en est que
nous sommes dans le discours politique
donc au delà de la beauté et des phrases
il existe un certain sens ans pour les
normes de droit à sa logique qui peut
être différent de la logique politique
le pays est en phase de transition
politique
c'est à dire que vladimir poutine et
sortants tout le monde sait ce qu'il y
aura derrière en revanche personne ne le
sait la russie fonctionne aujourd'hui
dans le cadre de la constitution avec un
président extrêmement fort il est
évident que quelle que soit la
personnalité du président qui sera
ensuite sa personnalité sera beaucoup
plus faible
cet objectif ça ne peut pas être
autrement il y a donc une certaine
volonté affichée de vouloir préserver le
fonctionnement des institutions en
transférant certaines compétences vers
le parlement n'est là justement est-ce
que la russie est prêt pour cela
ça c'est une question honnêtement qui
est largement discutable parce que pour
que le parlement puisse assumer ce rôle
que l'on veut lui faire cheminer en
prévision d'un président faible
il faudrait pour cela qu'ils aient des
partis politiques qui soient forts
or dans quelle mesure le parquet dinars
sia russie unie qui est le parti
présidentiel va longtemps survivre au
départ de la dig it in de la politique
réelle ça il faudra le voir mais
personnellement j'ai beaucoup de doutes
donc le problème est que il ya un
transfert des compétences
présidentielles des pouvoirs de
nomination qui sont des pouvoirs
extrêmement important pour déterminer
l'équipe avec laquelle vous allez
travailler donc la politique que vous
allez mettre en oeuvre et transférés
vers le parlement
or le parlement mais malheur
heureusement aujourd'hui pas mûre pour
assumer ses compétences puisque le
système des partis politiques est très
faible en russie il est très faible en
général dans le monde entier regardait
entrants sont partis politiques sont en
train de s'écraser les uns derrière les
autres
né en russie aussi puisque le pays est
en plan jeunes et que les parties mis en
place n'ont pas eu le temps de survivre
à leur leader donc on ne ressent pas
dans quelle mesure et sont viables ou
non c'est un pari qui est paraît il me
semble assez osé peut-être assez
dangereux mois laissant beaucoup karine
berger goal of cour d'avoir partagé
votre analyse sur notre plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes spécialiste en
droit russe est professeur invité à
l'université d'état de moscou